I was in Colorado and I met this guy
named Stevie and he's running across
America the opposite way all right and
we cross as a beautiful day and he
actually I mean God God bless Stevie but
he turned around and walked the wrong
way to talk with me all day why wasn't
it done I love Stevie but bro I'm not
going east broke sorry sorry dude were
you guys like grilling out in the
evening doing any fresh veggies or did
you have a yeah like a certain Cal to
work intake yeah a stupid one really
yeah I was wearing this thing this whoop
thing at the beginning I lost the
battery for it halfway through but it
would basically tell me my output
caloric output so we're just trying to
match it at the beginning it was like it
was spitting out crazy and only 8,000
10,000 but um I think NASA kind of think
as I as I walk more it might I started
getting more used to it and I was eating
a little less but yeah just eating a lot
of food man and me had to stop and [ __ ]
a lot too cuz he eating so much yeah
yeah I guess you got a lot of [ __ ] in
your body and I was the worst part not
the worst part but it's just how a lot
of times be like just pooping on the
side of her like man I want to keep
walking but it's like I hate that I
gotta stop again
I can't poop if I see broken glass near
me you know so I think some of that kind
of outdoor kind of stuff I don't have as
much strength when it comes to that why
broken glass oh it makes me nervous dude
why not
you know same problem I let my [ __ ]
open up you know saying like I'm no
Roman warrior but I know that you know
Mike thanks for being here today man uh
yes so you have and you have to your
buddies that are here today too I just
want you to acknowledge them I
- yeah man we let us know just let the
listeners over they are in case they
hear some yeah my buddy Julian's here
who was one of my walk managers
basically I walked supported which means
that I wasn't backpacking as I walked we
had support vehicle that Julian drove
and he basically sorted out a lot of
navigation and and the food basically
all I had to do was the miles wide
enough to carry everything on my back
and I always try to make that clear
because there are people out there right
now and every year who do it unsupported
is there beef is there a lot of street
beef between people know mostly
everyone's very very supportive of each
other every once in a while I got a
little bit I think you know just because
a lot more you know I was more of a
public figure when I started so I think
a few people kind of get their their
feathers ruffled but that's like 1% most
of the people are just really supportive
of each other and so Julian where he
would take turns there's another guy
calling basically Julian go home for a
few months and come come they'd switch
on and off
wow that's amazing had that much support
we were talking about it when you were
in the restroom but just to have that
much like yet have somebody that's just
so patient to be there they use the best
man he never really got flustered or
nothingness would you get pretty
flustered and not like would it be the
end of a day in your life yeah sometimes
you just tired at the end of the day
yeah but I'm like I go up and down you
know I go up and down for sure sometimes
you know I'm like bouncing off the walls
I'd be very goofy guy yeah other times
it's like a dog in me too
you know that's like the sports guy was
[ __ ] get it and I'm not [ __ ]
around yeah a guy comes out and so and
then it's everything in between and
there's like y'all might touch both of
those two three times and during the day
I noticed you said like yeah you takin
the calories and and you would start to
learn okay I have this input in this
output you know that's you know kind of
monitoring in the beginning did you
start to feel like a like a machine I
mean it the total you went 2,800 miles
in the beginning did you feel more like
a human and
the ending you feel like more like a
machine or did your humanity kind of
grow I know that's kind of a big
question but it just had me kind of
thinking about that now it was more the
second one it just became my normal life
you know this is what we do wake up 5:00
a.m. and see me wake up for ian's walk
it at 5:00 and you guys do it for a
pre-pre walk before the walk or any like
jog or anything before to like get
heated up the first thing I do
f4 is I meditate for 20-30 minutes and
then um Jun you have like a little fruit
out you know I have go a couple bananas
it's a peanut butter throw throw that
down the hole and and then a Filipino
Thanksgiving we have a lot of Filipino
listeners too man beautiful and it has
to stretch out a little bit and I just
try to get out the door as soon as
possible and that that's really because
it's a seasonal you know walking in the
summer you know you gotta get those
miles in before he knows 3:00 p.m. and
it's 95 with 95% humidity you wanna you
wanna already have 20 done then you
don't want to be on mile 8 then you know
yeah Wow so whether somebody's we
started late and you're like man you got
in a jam like that was that something
you kind of learned early like how to
you know learning curve must have been
pretty pretty steep huh yeah I've
figured it out you know just just what
worked best for me I think there's other
guys I talked to that either running or
walking across and damn more
loosey-goosey thing where they would and
I'm use that in a bad way they're just
able to wake up and kind of do what they
felt like doing that day but I don't
really work that way I got to wake up
the same time every day we got a rule on
the walk no snooze button yes lose
button no snooze names is it as a P
Diddy quote yeah he says two types of
people in the world I'll say hit the
snooze and those that don't and then
there's this David Goggins quote I love
about he said you don't hit the snooze
button because if you do you wake up
you're already failing damn
and it's just this is real so that thing
would go off you know 4:00 in the
morning and I never wanted to wake up
and walk zero days that I go oh yes for
a you know let's get none but the big
part of me you know the big part of me
that actually wanted to write to
accomplish this goal at the you know it
got me got my ass out of bed every day
and I thought you know when I set out in
this water I was gonna have kind of like
a hippy dippy free-flowing walk across
America I meet you meet somebody and I
stayed there in their town four or five
days catch the vibe but I start this
thing you know and at the beginning I
couldn't walk as many miles as I could
at the end obviously so the first day I
only walked eight miles you know on the
second day I think I got ten or
something like that yeah I start doing
the math and the whole thing you know
the whole the whole like scheduling
navigational part is really based around
the mountain ranges you don't want to be
in the Rocky Mountains in winter right
your [ __ ] yeah so I'm starting to do
the math you're gonna write one of those
books or you diet somebody else is going
right there but Chris McCandless or
whatever does I don't know who you ate
some bad berries or somewhere fruited oh
you know what the incident while yeah so
at least you got you only when covering
your fruit you know I'm saying tasting
the fruit for you first in the morning
and if he's still alive it's 6:15 you
like well it's [ __ ] Rock Road that
boy died had some bad berries or
something but that's right what
questions so I don't forget you did you
have a music that was on your alarm
every day that you would wake up to was
it just a nice is my watch
Otis your walk is just a watch alarm
yeah right just a pepper yeah well it's
interesting you know when I first
started the walk because I was removed
from basically all my friends and family
I noticed I was actually on my phone
more you know I always thought like I'll
be out in nature and then here lo and
behold I'm out walking across America
walking across New Jersey and
Pennsylvania and I'm on my phone like
all the time like I'm
taking pictures of every [ __ ] flower
and put them on instagram los [ __ ] and I
realize like I don't know a couple weeks
in our month in like what the [ __ ] you
doing you yeah like you could play on
your phone anyway hey you're missing it
started back even if we look at your
charlyk on the post I mean we have your
you know uh mike posner calm and it's it
shows your your walk across and the path
that you talk yeah it shows where you
had social media posts and there's a lot
in the beginning and then the second
half it's an eighth as much of it but i
mean it's interesting yes something
happened in there where you're like oh
man I'm well I started off yeah just
realizing I was [ __ ] missing it I was
on it too much and then I was in
Colorado and I met this guy named Stevie
and he's running across America the
opposite way
alright and we cross as a beautiful day
and he actually I mean God god bless
Stevie but he turned around and walked
the wrong way to talk with me all day I
want it done I love Stevie but bro I'm
not going east broke sorry sorry dude he
what
he walked with I got like that growing
up dude his boy yeah chocolate only in
one direction
yeah yeah that was which way huh which
direction was kind of like that
every time you saw him dude he was
coming at an angle and he walks
shoulder-first sure did was baffling bro
but you would see him you just be
hanging out around town you [ __ ] see
Shane go by brother like in one
direction saying shoulder-first dude
Otakon you know yeah just looking for I
don't know what he was looking forward
to pirate ships I don't know what he was
looking for a [ __ ] hot current that
dude was like it was almost like he was
caught on a air current just [ __ ]
cruise in the world but uh I don't know
what happened here
some might think some probably happened
here he left school was never his
shoulder first boy that he was short was
it hard to start to separate yourself
from from social media I mean cuz
there's there
this must be weeks where you don't do a
post where you don't have a social media
post I actually don't know if that's
exactly what the [ __ ] those stars mean
oh I'm not sure but no I wouldn't f
initely became less like you're saying I
would uh I stopped using my phone when I
was walking up anyway I've met Steven
here's the thing I'm s Stevie and this
guy blew at the time I'm walking
supported 24 miles a day and he is
running unsupported 30 to 40 miles per
day and not only that he looks at me he
goes yeah man
I didn't bring headphones on purpose
because I wanted to I wanted to face all
my demons and just be there and so
basically the two days after I met him I
got bit by a rattlesnake and I thought
it wasn't a big deal if I was going to
get the antivenin I'd be back walking
the next day turns out was a bigger deal
I thought I was in the ICU I'm in a
hospital five days takes me three weeks
to get back I start up at my spot that I
got bid at you walk up to the same exact
same exact spot Julian took me there I
was scared I was scared yeah what was
that like having a commit was what
happened during that three weeks that
was I mean I definitely went back and
saw some posts and stuff but what was um
was I saw one place you were talking
about how comfortable it was almost to
be back and like especially a hospital
like I loved surgery I love things where
they're taking care of you and
somebody's coming in and you know it's
lunch time it's valium it's Thursday
value just whatever it you know it's
like you it's just so much care for you
in like a in in a medical environment
you know there's the nurses there's just
constant care and it feels good and I
saw you uh talk about where yeah it was
like almost hard to let some of that you
know it was like you were back into this
really short like it's a real small part
of me you know you gotta understand at
the time I got bit by a snake I'm
walking pretty much eight hours a day
completely alone sweating it out you
know it's early August and [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hard man I couldn't really sleep
because it was so hot and so and my feet
felt like they were [ __ ] broken you
know I wake up in the morning
and it just felt terrible
no like I could barely stand up some
days was it the muscles the boner you
getting worn down like a blessing it
turns out his blisters too but it turns
out it was just the muscles they were
just sore in a way I'd never even
[ __ ] wrap my head around but but at
the time I thought they were broken I
thought I was gonna finish and I go to
doctor he's gonna be like dude we gotta
fix her feet you know but it was really
I was kind of a [ __ ] and I just hadn't
felt that kind of soreness and pain yet
and basically yeah I went to the
hospital and people I say man was that
the hardest day or walk it's like no I
wasn't even close man because they got
me there and you're right I was now out
of the heat I mean air conditioning and
now I'm not alone anymore I got actually
female nurses around yeah and like
doctors you know just making sure I'm
cool and you know you want something to
eat you just hit a buzzer to creation in
Salisbury steak in it wow you know like
online they're there this is outpouring
of sympathy and support oh it's a way
out even if you want it oh [ __ ] it [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know I couldn't hired a
snake to come out who he has been
training the snake for two months in
advance finally he let that bastard so
so that you know the weak part of me the
little meat he wants to stay there Wow
wants to stay getting all that attention
a nice food that air conditioning a nice
bed I'm off to get up at 4:00 you know
all that feels good and and it's very
easy I felt it evening myself a little
bit falling into kind of trying to milk
it and you staying you're staying in
that spot and that's that's what playing
the victim is yeah you know you're
actually creating suffering or making up
suffering that's not really there in
order to get attention basically to get
sympathy to have an excuse
and I had to just have a talk with
myself you know the big me had to talk
to the little meet and I say look you
you're getting better [ __ ] you
need to go finish what you started and I
you know the good thing is when I
started this you do something like this
and really do anything worthwhile in
life the shit's gonna be hard as you
know to get where you're sitting right
now it wasn't easy
yeah you know had to work a lot yeah how
much the only times you had to fail
stuff to be hard what you got now a
bajillion a lot yeah and so the thing is
you have to have a no matter what cause
in any contract you you got way your
self well I think it's just interesting
you're able to have that conversation
with yourself you know I've heard you
say it a couple times the little me and
that's right and we struggle with that I
struggle with that kind of stuff a lot
you know like the first part of me not
wanting to be not being strong enough
not wanting to you know not being brave
enough or not um thinking that I can or
wanting to take the easy way out you
know and and then of to just try and get
this bigger picture you know and just
tools to say look you know like you know
you you know um you got to move you know
you got to get going like you have to
there's this there's this this little
speed bump in the beginning and if you
can get over that then it's really it's
a lot different it's that bigger picture
you know but that little speed bump is
so powerful a lot of times man yeah if
you can see that you can have this
bigger you that's talking to this little
you yeah man I can I can just totally
relate to that you know yeah and a lot
of times you know to be more accurate I
didn't I didn't really have to talk to
myself in that moment because when I
started I decided I was gonna walk
across America yeah who anybody can say
that [ __ ] but and that's what I would
say publicly but what I would say to
myself is I'm going to walk across
America no matter what no matter what so
what's that mean I have I played the
[ __ ] out my head
if I break my leg out here I'm gonna let
that mother heal and we'll go to the
spot where I broke my leg and I'm gonna
finish I heard he had already visualized
that you know I already decided that so
when this snake thing happened I don't
have to have a conversation with myself
I have to decide you know and we're
gonna go back I knew right I'm going
back you know and and it helps you know
I had a lot of support to my homie chad
is here too you know sometimes I would
call him be like do my feet feel like he
go
yeah [ __ ] they're supposed to
you know remember you're walking across
America like that's what you signed up
for it so that you start reorient
yourself you ain't at the foot lock of
right Diezel pretty on count these these
that's the wrong adjective dude okay
sounds like my toenails are long [ __ ]
hairy feet or some fungus no dude no
it's like you start to you start to
reorient yourself around this hardship
because most of my life but basically my
whole life thirty years before I went on
this walk
it was oriented around making it more
comfortable hmm and just like a bunch of
[ __ ] you know so I hate you know
maybe if I play this game a little
better I get a little I moved from this
neighborhood in West Hollywood to this
neighborhood and [ __ ] in Hollywood
Hills and instead of this I'll date this
person and then I'll feel better and I
sort of zoom out on my life and realize
I'm just I'm playing in a [ __ ]
sandbox right now yeah
and I'm going hey Doc that toy that he
has over there looks nice let me try
let me try that one out you know all
that toy is cool let me try this toy out
and as we just wasting my life and I was
doing quote while I was supposed to do
right I was finishing my albums and I
and don't get me wrong I love all my my
music it's my heart but my life was sort
of designed by 21 year old me trying to
break into LA become famous and I'm 31
and I'm living the same [ __ ]
lifestyle right and so there's this
there's this in congruence between who I
am
now and the life I'm living and the yeah
and the channel that you're kind of
still like kind of why and it's nobody's
fault but me it's nobody's fault but
mine and there is no one that's gonna
bring those two things into congruence
but me right I'll call my manager he's
gonna tell me go back on tour I love my
manager that's his job that's his job he
doesn't say you finished out we got
support down going tour you finished a
tour was getting her out right now
and he never said those words he'll
bright but no but that's there's nothing
and that's our supposed to do correct
and that's what I was supposed to do
right but also Elite slowly realized I'm
I'm living someone else's life you know
and that [ __ ] that thing [ __ ]
sneaks up on your ass man that's so full
size up on you it's not it's it's not
something like come to God moment or
anything it's like you just you slowly
realize man what I really want to do is
this walk and I'm not doing it I put it
off for five years Wow because something
always came up I had an excuse
each year and you caught it you guys
start the thing in spring for what we
talked about oh right yeah Rocky so
every spring on it something will come
up and you know then I then I go out on
the walk right step one take one step so
I do and I'm out there and as I'm going
I meet a lot of people and nice people
good people and they come up to me and
say hey you know what you're doing is
very inspiring
say thank you and they say you know I
really like to do something like that
one day mm-hmm but right now I don't
have enough time or I don't have enough
money or I'm too old or I'm too young I
heard all the yo that's insane right I
missed a little school I mean you gotta
walk you know I know that mean they be
college kids no 100% yes later they feel
so much pressure to go get it go get a
good job and be successful right away
they don't know I'm telling you me 280
right tell me mm just to you is she
happy in their real life and I'm sitting
there like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and it's not about walking across
America [ __ ] that as my that was my
dream right but whatever that thing is
for you you know 95 percent of people
listening to this 95 percent of people I
meet they got a thing like that and it's
not it doesn't have to be a drop
everything quit my job does have to be
that it's just a thing that you know you
want to do you are called to do and you
have an excuse why you're not [ __ ]
doing it right now you don't have an
excuse you have a reason I don't have
enough time enough money whatever it is
you have an excuse wearing a reason as a
cape that's what it is
and that's my contention to to your
listeners whatever that thing is where I
starting to business or whether it's
hitting the gym I don't give a [ __ ] what
it is and don't don't copy my dream
right [ __ ] you man that's my dream
yeah cut whatever your thing is and
York's your reason for not doing it
that's exactly right what you said
really look at it look in the mirror
that reason I can almost guarantee you
as a [ __ ] excuse yeah and it's just
your cop-out for not living your life
for taking the easy way out and amen
we're gonna die you know it's like a few
years ago my dad died and my my
collaborator Avicii he died some of my
peer guys do shows with Mac Miller he
died
in February one of my friends I grew up
with Ronnie died and it's like hey man
you know I'm gonna help the Obie's
hopefully there's no time soon but
you're gonna die one day too
yeah and you could either live your life
before that happens or not something you
meant yeah it's uh was did did some of
that that death that came in your life
is that do you feel like that was kind
of some of this stuff that that really
threw the gas on you know you said it
had been a few years where you kind of
you know something come up around the
spring time and what was it you think
that was that last thing was that you'd
already told too many people you were
gonna do this walk like how did that all
kind of where it's like okay I gotta
yeah I take this that was a couple
things really a one was when he died I
sound weird to say this but there's
something beautiful about death if you
haven't been around or how close one
died you will soon and each time that
happens I feel like there's this like
for me but it's about two weeks there
where all the [ __ ] traps up mind
games and I'm usually in they fade out
and I can see what's actually important
to me you know it's almost like other
people when they do die or whatever the
the thing that permeates from them is
this value of existence that was really
hits the rest of it a severe yeah
that's exactly right I think it I think
it's just that reminds you of your own
mortality and and and I I really believe
when you acknowledge you're gonna have a
death you can start to live a good life
and so the thing is I should always like
it only lasts for like a few weeks for
me yeah I go away I start to just get
caught up in [ __ ] and and so yeah
when Avicii died or it was a big it was
a big reminder and I remember just thing
like man I got it going well I actually
wanted to go like immediately but how to
have anything prepared enough this was I
already wait till the spring us when you
do it the right way
little jooheon can tell his mom he's
going out of thing you got a plan a
little bit that's
but go plan a lot you have to plan a lot
I mean a lot
you have planning a lot yeah yeah it's
so funny with that mortality man it's so
funny how yeah it's so funny when I had
a buddy that passed away a couple weeks
ago he died of addiction my friend Tommy
I'm sorry for any loss yeah thanks man
then he was a beautiful dude man and he
uh but yeah we went to his service and
it was just like man if he could be
doing anything he would just be alive
that's it you know that's the first
thing he would be you know and it's like
it's so hard to get a ration that to get
like a make your life feel tangible to
you sometimes as we get older you know
when you're young it feels like so um
you don't really have that much imagine
a lot but it feels magical yeah the
sense of awe yeah super Oh sense of awe
man and then we get older and it's
almost like we get so much in these
grooves of society and of life that it's
hard to get it back to a level where it
feels like tangible you know where it
feels um where you feel alive and not
just kind of part of what's going on one
that's right
that's one did you have it I can imagine
you probably had a lot of experiences of
feeling alive on this on this journey as
you as you talking it was like you
reminded me that was a that was why I
left he knows why I pulled the trigger
on this thing it was like friend of mine
sent me say he starts doing the math and
he's thinking about my career know stuff
he's looking you know he's going to take
you six months to a year and he says to
me
so you're basically giving up a year
your life to do this and I thought about
for a second yeah I got I'll basically
taking one back ain't giving up nothing
you know then now I'm now I'm claiming
some sovereignty I'm getting out of
those grooves you you're just talking
about yeah
so yeah I'm setting my grounds here I am
myself is this cool you know when I can
boil down you know that's pretty
powerful man to think about that of
taking your life back that's right you
know I can boil down there's a lot of
reasons why I walked you know some of
them are small some are big some of them
are
shitty reasons like one small reason is
I wanted to [ __ ] attention from it
I'm not proud of a character flaw right
right but I'll try to be real about it
but the main reason I went out if I can
really put I couldn't even articulate
this before I left it I had to do the
[ __ ] thing to be able to say it was I
wanted to become somebody that I was
actually proud of mmm so I want if
somebody say you know who inspires you
who's your hero who you look up to I
want to be able to look him in the eye
say me you know and say your self was
yeah oh wow yeah but but I'm creating
this dude in my head like that dude he
walked across America
so he's idea and then I go try to become
him in real life hmm and this is just my
idea it's like creating a life actually
inspires you right you know it's like
you're go my goal shouldn't be something
that like it's that like isn't inspire
isn't cool to me right I'd like this
walk you know it's [ __ ] cool it's a
little less cool to me now honestly now
I've done it now I made all these people
have done it like in more badass ways
and faster just to be totally honest but
like it just inspired me the whole way
you notice don't like other people I
talk about they're like dude you're an
idiot you are a crazy white person yeah
and I get that but this is not about you
it's about me and my life right and I
had to send it man and this journey for
me I had to do it it's from were you
amazed at some of the feelings that
started that like some of the reasoning
you did it started to become more clear
after you started like was that kind of
fascinating to you were you like holy
[ __ ] a finding was started on this I
would have never gotten to some of these
feelings and revelations and stuff for
myself because I couldn't even see them
before yeah I mean I felt like I still
do feel like a completely different
person you know I was a guy even if I
look at interviews and myself before why
it's kind of like sometimes I won't
punch the Duke guy in the face either
hey it's like that's quiet I don't even
I don't even know if other people could
see it but
I can see it right I was uh I was more I
would like if you were saying some stuff
I didn't really agree with I bet ya I
just [ __ ] agree with you I was more
always less real less authentic more
afraid of conflict man just just like
not as not as good a person I feel and I
thought I was gonna become I talked
earlier thoughts gonna have this like
kind of hippie-dippie walk and I was I
thought was gonna become like softer but
the opposite happening I had to tap in
the like discipline and focus every day
you know I became harder became harder
as a person was there yeah where there
were you surprised that some of the
toughness that was in you like what did
you ever kind of like to give some
moments where I could see imagine having
some moments like Jesus Christ man I
didn't know because I feel like for me I
always hope that there's certain there's
a certain person inside of me that I
don't get to see that much you know
there's like in power there's like you
know someone that's extremely confident
and very powerful and like did were you
amazed sometimes did did people that you
didn't know parts of yourself that you
didn't know did it did they come to the
surface sometimes yeah 100% you know is
that's awesome man so here's the thing
man imaginary I never even noticed
swimming up to the [ __ ] is surfing hey
Mike what up I'm in here too yeah before
I left I had this inkling that there was
more in me a little more in me than I
was letting out and I think I think
that's the problem with a lot especially
men is we know we got this [ __ ] I
know dog inside we got it got this
greatness untapped [ __ ] thing
and you don't know what the [ __ ] to do
with it where to point it and a lot of
times we can point it the wrong
direction and it if [ __ ] everything up
easy direction and I had this look I
just had this inkling there's a little
more in you than you are given to the
world so I went out
and I found I was wrong it's not a
little more use [ __ ] ton more than in
you man wow you know it's way more like
it's wit and I still don't know I feel
like I just scratched the surface of it
so you know now it's my job to keep
exploring and figure out what that looks
like for me and that's what I'm up to
now but here's the thing man it's not
like I'm a like you're not gonna
recognize me
I still got all my like I said GU fee
guy too but there's this dog part of me
you know that I think I was trying to
suppress a lot earlier in my life you
know and I look in the mirror you know
maybe do some affirmations or meditation
you say I am tough or I'm resilient but
it's like my name is Hawkeye or
something looks like you don't really
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Hawkeye I'll get
myself crazy man bro if you don't really
believe yourself cuz you haven't given
you haven't shown any evidence and right
in your real life so it's like go do
something [ __ ] tough and you you
actually don't need to do affirmation
right cuz it'll Bennett starts to live
in you this is you you did it ya did it
you did it
but so it is I'm still me you know but
it's no more of you now there's more of
me you know and and and I needed those
parts to come out some other dude you
know I'd be to [ __ ] argue maybe you
need to soften up a little yeah yeah oh
wait I want to take a different my
journeyman this was that's what I needed
yeah that Bernie man they say you don't
get the burn you want get the burn you
need and I feel like that about the walk
Cena so you don't get the walk you want
you get the walking need ah you know
what tell me about some of the vagrants
out there bro cuz I grew up you know we
grew up along I used to live back behind
the Sun they had a river behind us and
they had a rest area on the other side
of it that was a backup of the
interstate okay it's a rest area a lot
of men would meet up there you know
doing drugs doing sex you know rivers
doing sex dude oh yeah what is river sex
sex out there right by the river bro
yeah you know and so uh and anyway but a
lot of it was drug-induced kind of set
she knows a lot of these men probably
had families and
but they weren't doing drugs but did you
get to stop at any unique rest areas was
there uh was there some decent you know
decent you know road warriors out there
did hitchhikers look at you like I'll
look at this [ __ ] guy look at this
show off you know I looked at you know
at the time I had the big beard like I
do now being hat you know I had two
walking stick
I look pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah really
gate no one gave me really like much of
a hard time a few dogs came out you know
looking for looking for a looking the
tango I had to fend them off with my
sticks and what state was at him where
these dogs dog I mean they're in every
state but the the one that came at me
the most I too in Colorado Network line
thank my sketch but uh Danny I have some
dog spray - oh you did yeah yeah and
what flavor is that what is it that's
[ __ ] I don't know stay the [ __ ] away
it's nothing good I want to tell you my
my rest area story man alright yeah yeah
he's a good dude don't get too
comfortable ocean I like the way you say
yeah your voice drops are octave who the
[ __ ] yeah Jesus we're uh Ohio was it was
the city the Walmart
do you remember now it was close to
dating and the yeah I don't remember the
city name but we were in Columbus and
they were like where are you headed next
I forgot the city name it's a city west
of Columbus erisa macron no was an Akron
it's a smaller city but there's a
Walmart there
is there to the left is day in
Springfield yeah okay Greenfield
so we're in Columbus and everyone's
telling us yeah man just just be careful
when you get to Springfield you know
just just you know just watch out and
people say that to you the entire way
yeah and usually the place they warned
you about are the best places right so
I'm not really listening to him and
Julian you know part of his job would be
to figure out where we're gonna sleep
each night so like I said we had a
support vehicle so if there's Walmart's
we could usually park there they usually
let's park there and so just like that
there was a Walmart right on our on our
route which is perfect and he's like
that's where we'll stop to stop that
night so I get there and and I'll take
my shoes off you know I stretch and
stuff and I'm like hey Julian I'm gonna
go take a Dookie in the Walmart oh yeah
I'm doing that dude so let me go make a
deposit in the bank let me go drop the
kids off at school why are you laughing
at that there's nothing more I think
there's nothing more American than you
know pulling over to [ __ ] to watch
and I've done that and I love it I love
being in there except some other people
write stuff on the AH like the outside
wall I find a lot of people have markers
out there but anyway let me let me McGee
I found something worse than a Sharpie
Sharpie message I'm gonna stall I'm
gonna tell you what happened so I get to
the stall and back back stall all right
you know I think I'm in a freaking
handicap stall which I shouldn't be well
you know but come to exchange it is what
okay so elite opposite at being
handicapped is walking all the way to
the wall listen man listen I'm sitting
on this toilet okay and I've been on the
toilet for light
120 seconds all right I'm just getting
started
oh yeah all right told you how much I
rely on baby yeah it's like a breather I
got my phone out I'm comfortable to stay
in here download an episode of something
we're gonna be here listen man so like
I'm just in the prelims I hear something
knock on the door and I can see there's
another stall next to me empty mm-hmm
and you knock on the door they're like
hey are you okay I'm like yes I am okay
all right all right my [ __ ] spidey
sense is tingling dude why is this a
knocking on the door when there's open
stall here yeah that's alarming that's
alarming
so he's then he follows with do I know
you no bro
I can do it with no I go nope I go you
do not know me I am for clear as day you
do not know me you gonna know somebody
that's just in a [ __ ] about a door
unless you're David Blaine Bros I [ __ ]
it is dude he's like uh he's like um are
you sure I say yeah I'm sure I'm sure
he's like let me just check I think I
know you
oh I see - okay I'm sitting down at the
thing I see two hands with clear rubber
gloves on not rubber a lot like the
doctor has yeah but they're not like
that like like this like the subway
people where uh-huh you have to oh yeah
Wow dude do you doctor - at ease creep
over the the I'm looking at the top of
the thing the sandwich maker Mitchell
over the top over the top of the stall
he like a pull I off see - I like this
okay I see the eyes come over I'm
sitting down I'm
vulnerable position do what the [ __ ] are
you doing right now
okay me and Posner came out heed me it
wasn't the gun I'll go with the [ __ ] he
goes he drops back then
gloves disappear he goes oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry I go what the [ __ ] are you
he goes I just thought you needed help
you were in there a long time I go I've
been in here two minutes man what are
you talking about
I didn't hear anything else I think he
left the room boom fired up man
oh that's hard to [ __ ] when you're real
fired up yeah you know oh yeah I do
actually wasn't that hard - [ __ ] man
really yeah I finished my business so I
finished my bid for it up and I'm ready
to like fight this guy oh yeah and I
open the door he's not there and I was
using you know Sherlock pose you know
looking at those gloves I think he's
probably at the subway I think he's the
subways you go looking for I got looking
for one I never found them but I still
don't know what was like is there some
kind of weird meetup that happens in
that bat like what do you make what
Theory do you have to explain that I
could see man it was daytime daytime Oh
probably 4:30 p.m.
mmm I could see the Sun is out Sun is
out I could see people getting off work
and maybe you let me swallow before you
say this if you gave out a certain vibe
or something you walk through the store
do you think you were doing that well
you kind of peacock and as you went
through
um everywhere I went on this one I did
not feel stuck out so I'm perpetual
peacocking
he's one so maybe this guy had had
daydream that a man came in like you you
know maybe that's the thing you don't
know where his life is meeting you it
but that's why do do a pull-up in those
[ __ ] ah dude he popped up man
it was slow it was slow we thought you
were I'm thinking there's some sort of
weird weird meet up for like truckers oh
I'm sure there's like Tuesdays at 4:30
meet in the bat what the creek the
listen let's discuss why why the gloves
were on though how would you make of
that I think to not leave fingerprints
probably my god oh my god this in case
it gets real rectal or something you
never know what this variant real rectal
is that rectal bro you gotta have a
[ __ ] mitten on bro cuz this dude if
he's out there like that you know maybe
he's like a pianist but don't wanna you
know I don't know that's wild to me I
don't like wearing those I used to work
out of a sandwich place and I don't like
wearing those dude you know I hooked up
one time with Jared from Subway sister
one time a long time ago okay tell me
more that's it there's nothing but it
was a long time ago but it was still you
know it happened how did you know was
that who her brother was people knew she
knew you know that was very new before
you met her
oh no I'm ended up meeting her that
night and people like hands oh they were
telling you yeah okay um were there how
much fandom that you have across because
you're a UH I mean you were a superior
yes you're a very uh bigger big producer
musician entertainer thank and thinker I
think is is something that even more
people are probably gonna start to see
you as or something that I personally so
I can't speak for everybody but
appreciate that but did you how much
fandom did you run into or you know
people that are supporters and stuff
yeah well first of all I'll have some
popular music but uh I live a pretty
normal life most people don't know what
my face looks like which is pretty
awesome you know I can go to the store
or whatever and it's not a problem
there's a nice freedom with that huge
man if you I'm sure you have some
friends who are like really famous it's
scary
it sucks it does suck doesn't it it's
liked it a lot it just like extra work
to do to normal stuff and probably
something that takes you even further we
talk a lot about in here about like Fame
in the and and what is the real value in
it you know and what is like just how
how much of a sidetrack it can be to be
in a human huge you know I feel bad for
a lot of guys you see a lot
young guys these days who are struggling
because of the fame you know something
you can't live up to as a person just
has one person that's really um you
can't match that this fictional kind of
you know ambience or this crystal ball
you know that or this a disco ball
that's kind of created you can't just be
that as one person yeah and you see a
lot of people suck you know struggling
with it you know I mean even Justin
Bieber you see him recently come out
about opening up about a lot of his
struggles which i think is pretty cool
but just the value of fame I think is
it's it's not as valuable I think as a
lot of people think it is it's valuable
in this way yeah so much in this way
yeah as a sacrifice big-time big-time
but to answer your question man at the
beginning of my walk I i said publicly
I'll walk with anybody and so people
would come from all over and they'd walk
to me and it was very beautiful you know
my job when they showed up was to listen
mm-hmm that was my intention I [ __ ] it
up sometimes a lot you know because of
this are asking me questions I know so
I'm talking about myself
oh yeah no but my job really was to
listen and there's a lot of people came
and I would just ask you know every time
someone showed up hey why did you why
did you come here today what were you
looking for and not in the mean way just
just so I know right and it's always
different some people they just wanted
to go on like a wild goose chase
you know where they call it because
they've know roughly where I am but not
exactly and there's just a fun thing to
do on Saturday like Easter Egg like
you're like an easter egg especially
people they just want a picture but some
people have some [ __ ] they wanted to
talk about that they felt like you
couldn't tell anybody else you know so
it was just different every time and it
was really beautiful because even even
if somebody is real excited you know as
like a fan or something like that you
okay you know you walk like 2-3 mile the
Sun starts beating down on you real
quick
real quick you just you just to two
dudes out there yeah so it was really
cool that's addressing it's like you
could walk right out of your your
dislike in case and kind of that happens
sometimes yeah from people know when
unit bang it takes a minute and one of
my all comma mentor he's a hospice
chaplain he's Kevin Deegan chaplain
Kevin we call him and before I left he
kind of gave me a lecture on listening
and he said Mike there's three levels
and listening the first is contextual
meaning I say hey my dad died two years
ago it's just a fact because context and
the second is emotional my someone
stepped deeper and that's my dad died
two years ago and I felt lost and the
third is identity and that's my dad died
two years ago I felt lost but it was the
first time I felt like a man changed who
I was or the first time I felt like a
real adult and so if you he taught you
know if you can move the conversation
away from step one to two to three then
there can be healing he says he says you
know I mean like on that third level and
so I starts trying to listen to people
on this it's just certain cues and
questions he gave me where this just
like tell me more about that or heard
that you know what did that what did
that change for you he was a question
you can ask ask people and you're trying
to take it out a small talk yeah yeah
because you can really connect with
people at that level too and it makes it
so it feels so good to connect with
somebody at a level where where you're
both just human souls kind of that
because you can you know what it's like
to need something and when you hear
somebody needs something or there's
people are sharing what they need man
it's just such a magnet you know it's
such a comfortable place there's a gift
you can give to somebody else yeah
anytime yeah it's to really be there
really
it's pretty powerful huh yeah man and
the last one he gave me you know he said
if all that [ __ ] doesn't work
you bet saying goodbye you ask them if I
pray for you what should I pray for mmm
I asked that question about 20,000 times
on this walk you know just from New
Jersey to California and people will
tell you man
pray for my pray for me my sobriety pray
for my family in the Navajo Nation they
say pray for my people a lot you would
say that
pray for my people yeah and then you get
out you got a level-one get to go a
little deeper was that one of the most
proper angels people caring for the
survivors a lot of people lot of people
sobriety came out I would say like a lot
I want to say like a abnormal percentage
but yes some people aspect you know the
guy I'm thinking of when I say that his
and it was one of the most touching
things happen the whole walk is dude I
was walking in Arizona on the Hualapai
reservation and I have a sort of a end
of the day tough day I think I'm doing
24 26 and Skyy stops it poses a red
f-350 Paul's aside a road ahead of me
and it starts to reverse you know like
oh what's this gonna be like you know
and the more like a a two-lane busy
highways like you know speeding them 65
where was dangerous said dude he like
kind of dangerously like crosses the
road
I don't like oh gosh like don't get hit
by a car please bro and comes over and
he's talking to me so you know I just
been following you and it's a it's an
indigenous young man his name is Rowan
and we had this little little talk
honestly I was I was tired I wasn't
doing any of that [ __ ] chaplain Kevin
told me I wasn't really listening
think about myself I remember to ask him
that question I said if I pray for you
what should I pray for he said man and
he took a moment like that he's just you
know several years ago my dad died
alcohol you know alcoholism on those
reservation he died alcohol and a few
years after that Maya I think it was his
brother he died from alcohol and this is
like last year on Easter my mom died
alcohol and also your brother he's like
nah like I'm alone now so I always say
just pray for I have a problem with
alcohol - I'm sober now I can't remember
how long but just pray for my sobriety
mm-hmm you know and also [ __ ] I will you
know I will
he said you just wait wait here man I
want to get I got something for you he
runs across the road again back to his
dude I'll call you gonna get this guy
mezcal Vietnam Corvette so he goes up to
his truck and he had this little leather
pouch and it's tied to like you know you
drive the car like this and there's the
little handle there sometimes right it's
tied there real tight looped around
little leather pouch he undoes it he
brings over he say Amen this is uh this
is not in our tradition
this is a sweet grass and sage and we
believe sometimes spirits or Souls they
get lost right here where you're walking
and this is just you know in our
tradition we believe protect you and I
want you to have it out off foot
you know he left and he put his [ __ ]
hand off the window like this you know
drove I drove away from me I said just
after he left she just hit me right in
the heart and like how this guy man this
guy first off I'm a white guy walking on
his land you know right which probably
yeah but traditionally didn't really
work out well nah we [ __ ] we [ __ ] them
over every single type of way possible
you know how could this guy be so
welcoming to me so kind even after
everything is he's had such a hard run
yeah you know and his smile and yes one
of the most yeah touching moments that
whole walk man especially when you're
having a day with it's like yeah you're
at the end of the day so no you can't be
you know your best self after you know
it's it's hard you can't always be your
best self and do the thing you want to
do like you're saying like some of the
guideposts that the chaplain is giving
you and things like that in conversation
and yeah it happens a lot and it's like
you get into a moment you're like ah and
then somebody does for you which you you
know just want to be doing for them or
what you know it's like somebody brings
your journey what's your thing it's they
bring it right to you man that's
powerful powerful before I left I
brought these sort of like intentions
for myself and one of them was like I
said listen deeply and another one was
leave each place I go better than it was
when I came and I read that now and
that's one of the things I want to punch
ol Mike in the face like you you [ __ ]
cocky [ __ ] you think you're
gonna Breeze in to the Hualapai nation
and leave it better yeah then there were
no [ __ ]
you're gonna walk there and because of
people's not just there but everywhere
that you walked because of people's
kindness and grace they will leave you
better you know you know ii said i
reaiiy hear that now some people are
read in like two years
you saw so it's cringe-worthy yes you
were so cocky but it's an it's a it's an
it first
some weird reason it's a normal train of
thought you know it's like I used to
think like especially with the when our
podcast really started out you know a
lot of young men would reach out with
things ever struggling and I was
thinking like oh yeah this is great I
have an opportunity to be able to help
other people be a part of their life but
then over time it's like I've had so
many struggles on my own that these it's
like the people that support the pie are
always there for me so it's like I'm
sorry it's just interesting man it just
shows how much that we need each other
you know it really that's one thing that
I'm constantly you know reminded of all
right question for you yeah I know this
story or the I think it's the night you
got or dis I get sober Darryl Strawberry
that Darryl Strawberry but the amazing
man if anybody watching this hasn't seen
that they probably all have but thank
you much that means what what happened
the next day happen the next day did you
go to Center did what happened the next
day I flew back out here to Los Angeles
and and I've been partying before I even
left Los Angeles I've been doing some
cocaine and doing that and there was
still some cocaine on my counter even
when I got home oh [ __ ]
so I did they left a little booby trap
also the worst role so you came back and
did more cocaine yeah I had to man
because I left it right there you know
and and yeah so that at that point then
the next day I had some meetings and
stuff I was supposed to do work stuff
and I had to cancel it and I went into
an office of a manager that I had at the
time and he asked he was introducing me
to his his manager boss so the
management company was kind of trying to
take him some notice tell me what was
going on in my career and stuff mm-hmm
and he said hey what's going on and I
just told him and Darryl Strawberry I
just told him what happened you know I
just I wasn't doing well and I just said
you know I'm not really doing that well
you know is the first time I gone into a
place I guess and I don't know if was
the first time I going in and been
honest but yeah they're not thinking
about what did he you know what do I
need to do to make my work better
her career better or what try to
position myself and here
I said it has been struggling you know
I've been you know struggling with some
cocaine and doing some drug and he said
well I go to these meetings if you want
to go it was crazy because the guy who I
was kind of scared to talk to he said
well why don't you come with me to this
thing tomorrow you know I go to these
meetings and then the next day I went
and then I continued to just stay in
there you know and uh and start to
figure out some other stuff because my
alcoholism isn't really I don't know how
much have a problem with drugs and
alcohol but I have a problem with the
way that I think and feel about myself
and and it's a constant battle it
doesn't I can't just beat it you know
it's like it's one of those things that
keeps coming back you know I mean it's
that might positive right oh come back
day after day dude you don't say it'll
show up across the country broad day
after day it gets up it gets up before
me my alcoholism and it trains and it
meditates and it's ready brother that
[ __ ] comes it'll [ __ ] come off the
you know you open the cereal covered in
that [ __ ] will jump out with a
[ __ ] little dragon in his arm you
know it'll new stuff so it's like I have
to I got you know just it's a
never-ending battle continent but that's
what happened that was like the next day
that happened you still go to the same
meeting I do sometimes
hmm yeah not as much but I do and I go
to a lot of them still yeah you know had
me thinking when you were walking
everywhere I go people say that they're
their town is the math capital of the
world yeah you must heard that all the
time I never heard those words but
pretty much every place I went I mean it
yeah which struck me whether it was the
smallest town in Pennsylvania or
Indianapolis or you know st. Louis every
place I went I never saw it aside from a
lot of needles on the side of highway it
was especially in Pennsylvania I mean
those things are [ __ ] everywhere
really he had a lot of needles I always
had Neal's like sir they were syringes I
don't know if they had needles on the
band's I
right but every place I went I would
meet somebody who say we have a huge
drug problem here huge every place
that's wild and white black poor every
place on it yeah yeah that's one thing I
noticed in these programs this [ __ ]
doesn't discriminate you know I know
some most powerful people now in in
entertainment that are you know through
this program and I know people that that
have not that you know that have you
know haven't achieved any of their goals
really and now we're struggling with
them and and it's amazing to see like
the that that [ __ ] doesn't it'll get
anybody it's pretty powerful um sorry to
interrupt the episode here but I gotta
let you know about something that's very
crucial to your body and your existence
you know a lot of times you don't know
what's going on with yourself and then
sometimes it's not that and what I'm
talking about is figs I think there's
something all of us can agree on that
nurses doctors dentists and people who
work in medicine and healthcare are good
people they're pretty great they do
something special they contribute and
all of us can think of a time when a
medical professional helped us or helped
a family member
well figs uh which is a beautiful little
deal that I got from my sister because
she is a nurse figs is an amazing
company that is making scrubs stylish
and functional for the people who
deserve it most you don't want a nurse
coming in and she's dressed is like uh
you know she's wearing like a um just
like a life preserver or something like
a tank top that's insane
so figs creates the highest quality
medical apparel so that medical
professionals look their best
feel their best and perform at their
best every day every set of figs is anti
my cryo boo bill protects from germs and
bacteria ridiculously soft moisture
wicking and features four-way stretch
because if these people are saving
somebody's life they got to be able to
do it look if you have a nurse a doctor
somebody dentist somebody who works in
that field where they got to be clean
and professional
they might as well be stylish as well
and this is something great you can get
them now or for the holidays and figs
gives back every time you shop at figs
they give scrubs to healthcare providers
in need around the world through their
threads for threads initiative so
whether you're one of the awesome humans
that works in health care or someone
that wants to say thanks figs is going
to make that easy by providing you with
15% off your first purchase by using my
code Theo
that's right get ready to love your
scrubs head to where figs WEA are F IGS
calm and enter our code th EO at
checkout again these are people who are
doing the the Lord's work so might as
well garble up and make them look very
nice go to where figs calm and use code
Theo
today's we had some calls that came in
and we had it we had so many questions
we want to get to a couple of video
questions from from some soup they come
in video huh oh yeah oh boy Yeti's
people oh I mean it there's your boy
right there
what do you think his name is I'm gonna
go with Allen i'ma go with Jeremiah okay
that's Michael
Theo and Mike Mike congratulations man
I'm so happy for you for finishing that
walk doing what you said you were gonna
do you freaking delivered man so
congrats on that I have a question for
you about false finish lines we've seen
you mention that false finish lines have
been a big struggle on the walk you know
you make it to the end of a state then
you just got to keep going so my
question to you is how do you deal with
those false finish lines you know you
you want that reward in your brain you
want to be happy about what you've
accomplished but you just got to keep
going
so I'm curious like how you mentally and
physically deal with that right on
brother
gang gang guys gang bro thanks for the
question that's what all of them say to
you yeah man they say gang gang you just
say one gang bad gang yeah then but do
you ever say gang twice and they say
gang once yeah or you just you're like
the whoever starts the gangster
that's a double it let's try one alright
gang gang gang I didn't feel right okay
it just on my alright let me try felt
like my gang was an authentic I feel
like it was authentic to you though and
that's what cain't gang gang bro
that felt better okay I'm a better
leader I'm better first first okay man
Michael right yeah yeah great question
how're you know that that that finish
line I mean no there's so much more to
go to Rio Church and I got even this
does this nomenclature false finish line
or fake fight I got that from David
Goggins he did it post about that before
I was experiencing it but I didn't know
how to conceptualize it so just a little
background I was walking across Missouri
and one of our across Missouri is like
end of July it was foggy you know high
like 95 you know 90% you mid today and
you're completely covered I mean you
were you look completely cover I got our
word is the same sure I wear two shirt
on the walk I didn't wear this one too
much because his blue and I end up
wearing the white ones cuz they're
cooler but this is a walk shirt so I did
long sleeve dry fit but they this is a
coach chat help me out with this - is it
UV protectant oh man I never got a bunch
of complex believe it or not I never got
sunburn so you just this is see if I
ever had sunburn I get it and that's ten
die finished ten days ago you see that
yeah so only my hand got ten yeah yeah
cuz I always wear t-shirt Iran handed
bad boy yeah my whole body wow that's
amazing man alright so look I'm walking
in Missouri and it's hot and it's
flooded and I won't blow it off
proportion because people lost their
homes everything so mm-hmm I'm just
doing I'm just doing my walk so don't
feel too bad for me
right but there are days I'm walking the
wrong way because I get to erode and
it's just not there it's under water or
I get there and the waters come up to my
knees and I'm walking more
just come up to my hip I'm like dude I
got to go a different way like just
taken in good all right walking the O's
on the Katy Trail and I'm walking
through like nasty water like Stillwater
oh yeah and like so that's how I feel
like when I picture some parts of
Louisiana oh yes stagnant some swampy
water oh yeah look so I remember come on
as one water and my legs just stinging
just stinging I'm like Daniella I gotta
wash those off soon is is not good right
and there's no cell service there where
so we caught the old Fulton loop because
I had to go up to this city called
Fulton Missouri and it was like yeah it
was just the wrong way and it's
demoralizing walk in the wrong direction
day as you'd imagine but I kept saying
to myself man just get to Kansas dude
just get to Kansas
so that was for kind of my mantra in
Missouri just get to Kansas now a couple
weeks pass and what happens I get to
Kansas I crossed that border and I
[ __ ] cry bro I cry it was a Mac
because nobody knew how hard it was but
me you know and somebody else that did
the walkthrough I mean just nobody knew
and I thought I made it man I made it to
Kansas you know and it was the end of
the day where that border I went to bed
and I felt proud and I went to sleep and
the next day the alarm went off 4:00
a.m. you gonna start walking right so I
get up to go and my my mind my body my
spirit if you believe in that if you
don't want to believe in spirits called
morale my morale they were all gone
because they thought I was done mmm-hmm
because I kept telling them just get to
Kansas so they go we made it
[ __ ] got you here yep see you
later right right so this one this was
actually the hardest
walk for me I start to go and in
hindsight I think I was pretty bad too
hydrated as well but I get to a point
where I'm I'm limping and if my mind
isn't actively thinking walk right left
step walk if my mind isn't thinking if
it drifts at all to any other topic
anywhere my body just stops and I
finished my thought tangent and I
realize I'm not even I'm not moving Wow
and they'll be like I to be that focused
that's how just I just had nothing left
there's just no energy there man and and
my feet are frog and hurting bad and
there's like there's some trees and they
have shade and I will walk to like a
shade and I were like I was sit down and
try to just like cool off get my [ __ ]
together and I see like another tree or
another piece of shade and it'd be like
200 feet in front of me and I'd walk
there and my body just [ __ ] stop
again I sit down I was just going from
shade to shade right and they're not
very far apart and I'm taking a break at
each one and it's just so this is one I
learned this lesson minute you can't
create a finish line that isn't your
finish line so you got to break the
[ __ ] down you're nice to be like
hey man I got 2601 my last two big you
know so but you just you just going to
the next next checkpoint but you you
knowing that you're not done and so then
we got a new mod tractor that I got bit
by a snake hard [ __ ] I learned and doing
here he'll remember you know when we
like cross the Rocky Mountains or no
those were big deals cuz we had to plan
for him differently this kind of thing
whenever we'd finish some like that we'd
be excited we celebrate that [ __ ] we did
it you know for sure but we would always
say is saying that there's ain't a
finish line it's a checkpoint yeah this
ain't a fan we'd say you know we're a -
so we
as a Affinia sighs a checkpoint boy
that's a checkpoint boy that's that
checkpoint they don't finish my week
done
you know that's how that's how we would
do it after after I'd be excited to not
be done that's right we we done yeah you
stopped us there we done you know and
and so Evo even when I finished the walk
it's my best days you know best moments
in my life I got 30 people on them at
the beach waiting for me and I took a
vow of silence that day I walk up to
that beach and I had a moment with each
person didn't understand his shoulder so
we're looking at me the waters behind
them I could see the water they [ __ ] man
I made it here and I'm going down the
line hugging each person just having a
moment I'm listening they're talking to
me wine station I said I'm not saying
anything so I get in that water I seen
coach Chad there I start crying Wow
because you know I was the guy talked to
me and if you've been there every day
yeah talking me on phone most every day
you know before and he said my ear it
was never a doubt it was never a doubt I
keep going down that line you know all
the people you know guys I met and
Navajo Nation that drove there you know
barely any gas money because we
connected when I walked there wanted to
be there when I finished and last two
guys were Julian and Colin the other
walk manager he took turns and also
Julian's as I start crying to you he's
like man could get up give me a hug to
you and he said I we finished our moment
and the longer I go in the water and he
looked at me the same finish lines
checkpoint you know guy and we are model
to was keep going is another one more
mine yeah yeah not only that one yeah
for sure we do we do every time I was
say goodbye Julian the whole walk or
Colin I'm gonna go walk another eight
miles we got this keep going on baby
every time so we did that
and he just reminded me no even though
you're done with this journey you're not
done [ __ ]
this is actually just the beginning you
know because we talked about all this
stuff you became this new guy you found
parts of yourself you're stronger and
now you can do so much more
I mean the things I that are on my oh my
on the buffet now is so much more oh
yeah then that was before I did the walk
right with salad before you got into
dessert on there yeah he's on the ball
so it I'm gonna correct ya Sonic dude
you got [ __ ] oysters bro everything
they got a fresh catch area you [ __ ]
this thing is big dude that took the
sneeze guard off this is so so yeah you
know buffets gutter when they got that
[ __ ]
I wanted yeah that's so you can't lean
in don't you I don't want you to in
there they have it for you dude Theo von
Zakaria these look good Jesus Stan I
wonder why they all why don't they put
them on a better uh you know mobile
because they always got these shady kind
of piece of glass up at the top you're
always doing like this oh my god should
have been a surgeon I'm just trying to
get a a couple of [ __ ] potatoes bread
that's crazy man I didn't know that wow
that's a safety sneeze go so so listen
dude so you ran into the water I ran in
the water but I wanted I wanted to not
make that mistake again hmm
so my body's pretty jacked you know it's
not injured but it's pretty jacked up
you know my fear hurting and all stuff
but I know the next day after the walks
the most important day of the walk you
know go care you go we learn too much
stuff taps empower yourself and you go
the next day you forget it all
who cares
hmm anybody can do that so so how do we
do that how do we keep that going well
this is this is haben and I'm this end
of ten days ago so I'll tell you where
I'm at you know but the next day was
very important to me and I knew I knew I
needed rest you know for my body but in
order to not [ __ ] this mistake up I knew
I had to be up at 4:00 a.m. again the
next day and I knew I had to I knew I
had to get after it so I called a dude
named coach Marcello
he runs a boxing gym mm-hmm Argentinean
man I say hey man can you meet me at
5:30 Saturday I'm doing this you know
like a week before I finished the walk I
think you mean me 5:30 Saturday I'll
plant in my head that's cool you mean
and he said yeah I confirmed for I said
I can't confirm I'm turning my phone off
Friday I'm leaving my phone off for two
days after that exciting you confirmed
now can meet me 5:30 I'll be there so
I'm up at 4:00 I hit that meditation I
ride my bike over to the boxing gym and
I [ __ ] jump the rope I hit the heavy
bag I hit the mitts I do to sit-ups he's
throwing the medicine ball and this [ __ ]
my body nice arrest I know that but hey
I need I also need my body my mind my
spirit to know I'm not done so that's
why I did the next day and I just know
after that it's a physical therapy and I
just kept my phone off for two days
because I knew I needed to feel how I
felt without having to explain other
people how I felt and I wrote about it
but I just try to keep that that first
week I gave myself this week I let
myself sleep a little bit course I
needed you know what that first you
compressed a little I needed I needed to
keep that that schedule and I thought I
was gonna get depressed you know you
finish this big thing but I really
haven't you know and that's because even
though I'm not on the walk I'm I'm
working on other things where there's
writing I'm doing this
writing a pro-style which is exciting to
me and difficult and he's still walking
inside himself do you find he find
yourself kind of like like the steps
kind of keep going inside of yourself
sometimes can you still feel them and
you're in your being kind of I don't
know if I will put it put it quite like
that but yeah if we feel like I left the
walk and with the walk never leaves you
yeah yeah sure do your legs sometimes be
like dude take me for a walk right here
like I feel like it would be like having
a couple Bank Dobermans oh yeah yeah you
know they've been pretty tired dude but
me of course Chad just start hitting
some hikes cuz they want things I want
to get into his mountaineering mm-hmm so
instead walking on flats going that way
so we we've been we've been going
thinking some height me he took me
awesome [ __ ] yeah he's out of
Louisiana right he's in flatland I don't
know I would not let that man at an
altitude so I don't know we're doing up
there with him dude he's got machetes
out and [ __ ] yeah and you know just out
of Carl's jr. it's like what the hell
scope you don't want to see this guy on
a Saturday bro neela see him
it's dangerous huh yeah something get
real dangerous on the weekend I've seen
Cameron Haines and some of those guys
they get rid of dangerous on the weekend
has he come on your podcast very violent
no he hasn't
you may I don't want no I haven't even
met him we just communicated sometimes
online but he's really uh dudes pretty
gnarly a seems pretty normal
ones like a marathon a day he doesn't
stop we got this question that came in
right here from me when I was younger I
would well you think his name is oh man
I'm gonna go with the Scott that's Jeff
that's a good that's a strong Jeff hey
what's up - what's up Mike it's been
yeah or as Mike knows me by BC Birdman I
know I don't know we walked together
back in Indiana around
Oh miles around Terre Haute so what I
want to ask Mike is that you had you
told me oh I remember this dude he
changed his whole [ __ ] have mustache
like that
dude oh my because of Movember what this
guy was dope man
yeah man Deana that you developed a love
for a Ford f-150s that's first of all is
there any plans to buy it by an F Ford
f-150 for your own and then also it's
all about anything on the walk later on
that after we stopped walking with you
that you came to love or came to
appreciate that you didn't think you
would or that you just couldn't expect I
remember this guy
he walked to me and I remember he had he
got a hat that looked like mine kinda oh
cool and this guy is a bird enthusiasts
oh wow so he will he talked me on the
walk you know we walk a few hours he
will be like going camo and like he has
these long lenses and sometimes they
call the cops on him cuz he looks scary
yeah he's got these long lenses cuz he's
trying to get this shot of this bird you
know and he'll be just camped on the
grass waiting for that oh yeah the shot
on birds like that
- so f-150 yeah I realize like man
everyone has an f1 always lived in a
city or suburb really you don't see
trucks here now um you never seen a
truck you never see a truck dude but you
only walk everyone has a f-150 everyone
is a lot of marrakesh trucks you never
see them
I started love these up and then I
realized the rest f250s and you know and
there's a three fifties I don't know a
new favorite car after he met me became
the f7 50 is essa' it's like the it's
like a front cab of a semi oh I can't
even imagine that's a big boy oh don't
want all that dude just relax 750 you
put your hands on the table easy well
let me put my gloves on first maybe that
was me back there I wouldn't be
surprised
well that's an f7 v yeah big boy but
normally they're not they don't have
like see that looks weird because it has
has the regular back usually they have
like a dump truck or something on the
back like that yeah I never even seen
season to have that buy our CDs I see
them come up I go out the SF 750 I start
typing it up and then either if it's big
like that either 650 or 750 if it comes
by and they says on the side of the car
so I'm looking at coming right I mmm I'm
getting excited it comes by says 650 I'm
like man you hate to see it but it comes
by like this and says 750 oh I might
even run a little bit I see that boy
it's a little thing I get you going huh
- I think like another pound or just a
thing second parties question any other
things I learned or I didn't expect I
thinking pop my head was hunters man
I always thought hunters didn't give a
[ __ ] about animals right I thought they
were like the people that they hated and
like [ __ ] your animals kill me soon you
know so it turns out these are all the
hunters I met they actually care about
animals more than anybody yeah and what
I learned was you know you could live in
LA in West Hollywood you buy a [ __ ]
burger and what you're basically doing
is paying somebody else to you know
factory farm these poor cows and [ __ ]
kill them in a terrible way and you're
you know your pet you're funding the
genocide basically you know but you're a
hunter like some of the guys I met and
you find out one it's just very regulate
you know a certain time you get the tags
yeah I remember November is this yeah
and you got and you got the only giving
out the tag so you don't decimate the
population you're not hunting the babies
on you know so there's all that and then
where they taught me I always asked 100
I was like man so if you see a deer that
you wear you sure you shoot a light in
the head and like no you don't want to
shoot a deer in the head you're like
okay Saint Casino I didn't know dude I
no me do you tell me where a stream is I
thought I thought you just you see the
enemy shoot that shoot them that's what
I thought they did you know but I found
out they wait so they can kill it in a
way where it won't suffer where it's
going to be dead so even if they could
see the animal or the animals in the
scope if it doesn't turn in the right
way and they don't get a clean shot they
don't kill it and they that that I
learned that changed my whole
perspective what I thought hunting was
you know these people doing this is you
like basically you know you're in the
food chain then yeah you know if it
seems very ethical to me you had a lot
of small areas of meter spectacles
killing could be you know that would be
it more bears more ethical to me than
find a burger at the store right and
they use it especially locally you know
I'll get calls on the back in Louisiana
hey you know we have some venison and we
got this so we got some quail you know
or we got a [ __ ] fresh load of
[ __ ] hamp me what about those dudes
they come this is a real thing they that
cuz I seen a lot of roadkill as you
might imagine
others do they pick up the roadkill mmm
eat it mmm I think as long as they cook
it and eat it that's fine did you ever
have any roadkill they doing that
[ __ ] highway sashimi brah
did you ever have any road kill me I've
had a lot of exotic meat that was
probably killed I wouldn't know if it
was killed by an auto but I bet it was
killed by something you know fast and
like necessary like what exactly I want
people know I've had a lo me I've had um
oh yeah what else sure I wouldn't say
I've had gerbil but I've had something
just so touch bigger than that probably
like a little maybe a muskrat yeah I'm
trying to think of what else you could
be thinking maybe a large groundhog what
else do they have yeah man we came up an
area that a lot of exotic meats you know
I've had a guinea pig large ones nothing
small I've had enough I've had dove yeah
couple brothers near me stall we be
grilling up doves and I go get over
there and eat it with them once the
doves fly Neroni cheetah
again I think they catch them you know
catching with their hand as a dove will
come over brother that's the [ __ ]
Bible trying to reach out to your home
window you can't catch a double hands
Road I can't
but these chefs could these local chefs
we had one or two more video questions
that came in man this is just
I mean it's wild cuz I could talk to you
I mean there's just so much to
encapsulate that that you started a
feeding that you took it on and that you
really did it
hey man this thing and it must be hard
for you is it hard to to corral all like
all of the levels of it the physical the
emotional the yeah but that's one reason
I told you I'm doing that writing now
cuz then I can start to see what I'm
yeah but I asked a lot of stuff I'm
saying today I'll be like I'll like ever
feel that kind of think out cuz I'm
writing it to myself it'll be a book or
some where people can um you know get
old I'm nothing it could be helpful to
people I really think it could be I
think I think I don't know phone if I'm
called to do I'll do it
yeah I got once you know if I'm gonna do
a book I'm a writer you know right-mouse
alright other people's songs so I
couldn't use I could ghost write or
anything like that you have to do it
yourself and you know you did a book
it's gonna be hard it's as hard as the
walk you know it's gonna take you longer
for sure walk took six months you know
it's true you do that book yeah if you
do it right and you know it's gonna take
three four five six seven year you know
so I keep going man I love going baby
keep going this guy has a question right
here we'll get what's-his-name to us
Alberto Oh hold on okay Albert or
Alberta i'ma go with Edwin uh he didn't
really say put his name a Silver Fox so
oh sure we were way off here well he's
so he's must be Native American netted
Native American name hi Mike this is the
Silver Fox here it's his hair he's
referring lost my father four months ago
and I have reoccurring dreams with him
in the dream and I was wondering if you
think that it's a mechanism to help your
brain cope with the trauma or if there's
more to it and if you've experienced
that yourself
gang gang gang gang bro
Silver Fox yeah I felt balanced joke at
the beginning of that it's okay you
didn't know but I would I was about to
joke even and I didn't but dude my dad
came and visited me in a dream recently
in Hawaii I was in Hawaii I hadn't seen
my dad in 20 years and he showed up in a
dreamless was a dream he was there
Matthew McConaughey was there and Robert
De Niro was there and there there was a
kind of an argument it was at lunch and
uh and I was trying to get everybody to
communicate but didn't hear I didn't
want to talk to my dad
McConaughey was a little bit indifferent
but it ended up they chatted for a
minute and I don't know what it was all
about but that was just the dream and
then I got to just see my dad I just
hadn't seen him and he was younger then
I never met him at and it was just wow
it was crazy and it was just I mean I
never had it had not no dream and then
I'm in Hawaii you know when he died 20
years ago no he died about I think maybe
yeah he got about 20 or 22 years ago me
too
but it was just to see him just to have
like a moment where I thought I was
really there with him you know yeah and
I know your father passed yeah do you
feel like there was was there moments
where where he was with you was there
moments or was it a disconnect what was
her know this is actually a crazy
question because um it happen all the
time when I started walking like it is
crazy
it was crab me out stole my friends
while they do I see my dad or my I had
dreams about my dad I already feel like
but some people believe different things
I don't really feel like that's him
visiting me I don't really believe that
but out so I would say I'm having dreams
about my dad but yeah be all the time
and so much more than when I was on the
walk and I wake up and I remember just
feeling like say a saint similar to you
you're mostly in the dreams because my
dad he got brain cancer in the last like
year 10 months he was really like dying
he was in the hospital bed I kind of
think he was sick mmm and in the dreams
he's never sick he's I saw it's more
like a few years before it has to state
his body's and he's in and
I remember the feeling like when I'd
either wait after I'd wake up or to
think feeling was was always like almost
shock like he's really dead he's really
gone and I remember feeling like how sad
it was outside it really was a house how
like how real like then I remembered
that the whole like the whole deal that
happened with right with the when he was
sick it almost refreshes it because
refresh they were there for a second in
your head but even it feels more like it
felt it felt more heavy than it did when
I was there like I helped it take care
of Moss because I was just doing it then
and I don't had to make sure I was doing
a good job and I look back and I just
remember the feeling was like [ __ ] man
that [ __ ] really happened dad got cancer
and he died
[ __ ] you know I don't really know what
to what to do with that you know I would
wake up and I would take care of what I
said I was going to take care of if I
had the theorize to silver-fox
our thing is probably again I'm [ __ ]
psychologist broads this year I would
guess like it's my it's me feeling what
I need to feel and maybe I maybe I'm
cruising so hard and now I'm doing all
the stuff I'm busy on she's good you
know I don't feel bad about any of that
but maybe I didn't feel all that all the
pain all the grief I needed to so it's
coming coming at night that's that's I
so I would guess you did your thought
was it easier to go to sleep at night or
was it harder to go to sleep at night on
the wall and I would feel it would seem
like you'd be so exhausted but that's
just what I would think it would be
little like waves you got to catch you
know like I was trying to get to bed
7:30 because I knew I knew I wouldn't
fall asleep right some but I was trying
when I was trying to be like in the bed
you know starting the process and you in
a camper you in the Winnebago when you
sleep you guys get a hotel mostly every
once in a while but mostly yeah we had
an RV that was our support vehicle but
then when we would
do the actual like parts that were like
the Rocky Mountains or certain parts of
the desert in Arizona like the art of
Mojave Desert in California the army
couldn't drive on up those parts so then
obviously been intent but that was the
best part to sleeping in at any time we
had finished those we'd come back we are
RV we called Larry we come back Julie
we've like man I love Larry but kind of
like [ __ ] Larry but I don't need them we
ma it would be hard especially in the
summer was hot I wasn't sleeping too
well
yeah yeah yeah it's hard it is hard to
sleep when it's so hot I was in Nam and
Maui this summer for just a week
humblebrag
yep an island [ __ ] hungover activity
and uh and I don't have any air
condition in a hotel room and it was
hard to sleep at night Dave looks like a
[ __ ] promoter put you up there to it
don't worry Theo all expenses paid just
come on out it'll be a great time man I
would put a couple of ices on my back
yeah I would lay down and put some ice
that's right that's right let's get one
more question man and we'll quit taking
up all of Mike's day hey I'm here for
you this is awesome man oh wait let me
guess the name
um I'm stumped yeah me about something
about the way his eyes got caught in
that frame one's bigger than the other
yeah I'll go with uh Shane I'll go
that's a damn good guess thanks for a
[ __ ] man you are good but let's see
that's a [ __ ] shame though hold on
did he say his name wait wait I got a
guess hold on imma go it I would go at
Michael you didn't say his name it's a
Finn Sanders Finn damn close to Shane
yeah I feel like they're in the same
neighborhood yeah you got to get a
regular
you got a [ __ ] Wow that we didn't do
it do we have any crazy guesses you know
I don't know why I didn't guess you
should you should have guessed that I
should have guessed Bartholomew that
would have been all right come on then
the discussion topic that I want to talk
about is regarding Mike's philosophy on
life which I have been trying to adopt
loving people
forgiving understanding I just wonder
where do you draw the line when you
recognize actually malevolent and
pathological behavior do you still think
you can exterminate stuff like that with
love and understanding or do you think
that you sometimes have to draw a line
think thank you to both for what you're
doing
this is the club of the year Gang Gang
gay game bro laughter that's signal good
good brain if you just fight with it
because it came out I came out like my
stomach yeah it Naumann out my brain
yeah you know first time did I was
trying to sound cool here you're stuck
in yet though I was thinking about a
game that got or the game game yeah that
is Suffolk gang and I'm gonna you gotta
get that gutter I want to hear what I
want to hear you answering a question
too because it's a good one especially
your recovery I know forgiveness is a
big part of that yeah I think I think
you have to do your best you know I
think that not like I think almost
everybody almost everybody you can find
a way to relate to almost everybody and
I think there's instances where you
can't and for me my instincts will
usually kind of let me know like this is
something this is someone you can work
with and learn from or you guys can you
know you guys can be a part of each
other's lives or help each other in some
way and this is something that's out of
your capable jurisdiction there's
nothing if you continue to engage here
that you're gonna be able to to get to
help each other it's just not a good
match that's for a higher power that's
something that you can't handle and so
you know that's where I kind of I think
I'll just trust my instincts some time
and tried it and that's where I'll draw
the line if something something's pure
evil but it's just something that I
can't really help I can't help or it
can't help me even in a in a positive
way like you know just in any type of
emotional way or anything you know yeah
I think sometimes it's out of my hand
I'm not you know I'm just a layman of
the of the higher powers so it's like
you know a lot of times I need more help
than I have there's a lot some time you
do run across some people or it's just
they need to send this person back into
the drawing board back into the ether
and let them get them remodeled you know
no [ __ ] dude sometimes I think well he
chose Dark Arts you talk about killing
them I mean I ain't killing them broad
but I'll come to the funeral
oh you know it's the dark arts man it
doesn't end Mike it doesn't end I think
man I think is a difference between
forgiveness and who you spent you choose
to spend your time with I spend your
life with really forgiveness is for
yourself you know really I think I'm
looking at you like you asked me to
question you you know it's okay I think
I love it
hey listen bro hey listen my forgiveness
for yourself you know somebody [ __ ] you
okay so you then you got to carry it out
you notice they always say like you hate
somebody they don't feel that hate you
feel the [ __ ] it you got to walk
around that you know and so I think the
forgiveness is for yourself
yeah but then at the same time like I
think this is where I'm at right now in
my life if you asked me a year ago out
thing I'd say something very different
but right now I think um I'm a 31 year
old man part of my job is to be
respectful but also not be disrespected
so somebody's gonna disrespect me or
even like if I first meet someone
and just feels off that's cool I'm gonna
be nice to you but I'm we're not gonna
be free
you know I'm not gonna go be friends are
you just right just to be not because
you asked to have dinner with me or
whatever is I'm good you know so and
then it goes same thing sometimes
someone you love might do some [ __ ] that
you think is disrespectful and one of
the big things for me is our always in
the past just because I also scare
conflict
I just withdraw and maybe I just like
avoid them or maybe I don't avoid them
but I got this little thing in the back
of my head going remember that one
[ __ ] tiny resentment yeah that
resentment and now I think part of my
job you know as a as to myself is to not
allow myself to be disrespected or if
I'm disrespecting my boys calm out on an
a [ __ ] I don't like the way you
said that to me dude yeah you know and
you can do that with love - it's
interesting how you can and it can be a
moment for them like a whole man you're
right and they can learn and it actually
can help help them not do that in
another part of their lives or sometimes
you you saw you read it [ __ ] wrong
and you know and they get you you get to
get to the bottom of it yeah I had a
friend of mine one of my best friends do
he was there on the beach he's a he's a
he's an interventionist so he travels
250 days a year that's amazing do heat
this guy I would love to have him come
up with every willing to come on here
and talk about that I can't speak for
him right
I love for him to he [ __ ] should but
we'll see okay but at the very least man
list sometime like the three of us eat
or even if I'm not there you should meet
him so I'd love to me in a man he's oh
he's older than us - I love when I love
about a man cuz he just our first time I
met her I thought like this got his eyes
were kind gone like this dude's an angel
rub like that you know and you've meet
someone this bad wise kind it's like the
opposite yeah yeah but he's you know
he's in recovery 33 years and
imagine him being on the front lines of
seeing somebody have a moment that start
to change our life that's his job every
day
that's crazy perfect day and why'd I
bring him up were we talking about
we're talking about just like how
sometimes you know you can um I don't
know I know why he said to me dopey [ __ ]
about resentment hmm because one time
when I first met him he had texted me a
few times and I missed it and the second
time he called left a message all day
all yeah I'll call him later [ __ ]
forgot like three three times I
basically blew him off and I called him
back eventually he said hey you know you
made it pretty clear to me that you
didn't want to continue our relationship
and that's not how I felt at all I just
felt like hey I'm [ __ ] artist I'll
have to call people back everybody
understands I'm doing an important [ __ ]
which I'm not really right you know I'm
just doing my like it's not any more
important than anybody else's but in my
head that's really what I [ __ ]
thought and then he said you look me
made it pretty clear you didn't want to
continue the relationship but now you
call me so I see you do but I wrote you
a an email just getting ready to send
and I'm gonna send it anyway so you can
see where I'm at and because resentment
has an appetite I could never satisfy
and I thought just stuck with me man
it's like you got a problem with
somebody even if your problem is not
just what you gotta you got to say it
you know you gotta say it that was yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he just called me out
my [ __ ] thank ya it's nice when
something had come through enough and
touch you especially like in Hollywood
you know it's ego is so dangerous and
it's easy and it happens to us without
us even knowing it so over the years ro
sneaks it's crazy
slips like that sneaking in [ __ ]
[ __ ] you dog it's not even like this
snake bro it's like a snake that bites
you real slow over like a romantic snake
yeah the snake is like you gonna
hospital mud but you know did you feel
when that snake got you like it was
something did was it anybody in
particular do you like Oh somebody sent
this snake like was your hair that's
some Louisiana damn it Jeffrey he got me
good snake came all the way up to
interstate snake go don't go by the
interstate you wouldn't think it would
have been like if I walked across the
Louisiana you think that would have been
pretty cool there's a lot of drunk
drivers down there that's the only risky
part outside of that yeah I think it
would have been but I got someone else
swampy areas oh dude your crotch would
have definitely yeah you're not sort of
turn into a real hornet's nest I bet oh
my gosh dude cuz ya animals can live
inside of your body down there they find
dead people all the time they find a
little animal and I'm like damn what is
this what they died first an animal went
in who animal went in and killed them
from inside that a lot of people think
that how then we'll get it like what
cayenne what about some of those gerbils
[Laughter]
by at night man you've been putting on
weight you won't even [ __ ] know you
won't even notice Mike I would notice to
speak I could see you in my bed I
wouldn't notice man Mike walked across
America and uh and it's it's almost like
you you went all that way to see to meet
yourself in some ways man well 100
percent 90 percent dude it's captivating
man it's really really inspiring were
you were you amazed by how many people
were inspired by uh like who got on
board I started to really feel
inspiration from you yeah it was pretty
great cuz you know doing your doing the
thing for yourself and then like I said
it was the shitty part of me as doing it
for attention you know if you're able to
recognize that and say those two gotta
say it is a smaller part email us but
it's there but mainly you know and as I
went along they got smaller and I really
like after I buy snake I shut down
everybody walk with me cuz I don't want
anybody else to get hurt and it really
became more like my journey you know
and this is this hard note because when
I started to walk I thought when I
finished I'm gonna go when I get to LA
I'm gonna I'm gonna post on Instagram
and I'm gonna walk across LA I'm gonna
have like a thousand people behind oh
yeah I'm sure they'll be in our head you
know I'm gonna have this like news
helicopter aid missiles and then as I as
I got closer I go dude you don't even
[ __ ] want that all you want to do is
be there with the people you love the
most you know it's not even the people
you love most be there with the people
you want to see in that moment and I
didn't I didn't blow it up but I
actually did the officer I did a post on
I'm like hey men because you guys know
I'm getting close and some of you some
people been writing in like can we walk
with you can we meet you at the end
mm-hmm and I said no you can't you know
you can't walk with me that day I'm
taking a vow of silence I'm not taking
any [ __ ] selfies that day I'm going
to finish it alone for me and that's
really what I wanted and I had to ask
for what I wanted and you know what
happened I walked across the aisle a
minute
people recognized me all of them respect
him that Wow and they said you know he
said Mike you're not trying to slow you
down I was you know finished up or keep
going everybody was cool with it
and but it's praise you had to ask
yourself for what you wanted that's
really and I asked myself but what I
wanted what I'm saying is it changed
right
the guy who the guys started to I had
this had this goofy vision and get this
validation from a lot of people being
there
he wasn't that's not really the guy that
that made it to the other side so it is
interesting like because I think part of
that attention wanting part of myself
had to be there for me to start but then
when I did the thing man like that thing
kind of died a little bit along the way
you know he didn't make it across the
area yeah oh maybe a little bit he made
it cross probably he's a little weaker
now I like that
man thank you so much Mike for coming
and talk anytime and and I just want to
add last name I know you wrapping it up
but I didn't say this on the on the
record I told you before us how this
whole thing started was a you know in
between my segments I would break up my
day 8 8 mg 8 and then 8 8 4 4 s makes 24
and I so he got a little longer towards
the end but in between all my rips
that's why I called him on my eighth
mile rips a lot of times we would put
your [ __ ] on there just [ __ ] cuz it's
hard out there's a grind
I can't I'm saying me and Julian would
be on there you just put your [ __ ] up we
like to this guy yeah we'd be laughing
so hard and then we could just this one
video you know we lose service yeah but
what will you lose service one D'Avanzo
guy last you like a month that nocturnal
bus see we just like idly you know I'll
leave I'd walk eight miles you know
takes me to two and a half two hours 45
whatever I come back man I like dude I'm
chasing that bus dude that dream busty
you know we just repeat that [ __ ] for
like a month
yeah one joke that's awesome man I want
joke Attica be part of no you helped so
much man so I'm saying chasing that bus
man that [ __ ] is there's nothing like it
they get it while you can bro that [ __ ]
gets few and far between brother see
your rust maybe the bus older yeah man
it thing God man there's nothing better
than just just blowing up in your sleep
right you have to do anything and the
girls usually beautiful usually a girl
you're really like some nightmare dream
guys is a nightmare dream bus Oh
horrible I've never even heard of that
yeah it's where is who wouldn't come in
a nightmare
no I'm having sex in the dream but it's
with a person I don't like oh and in the
end in the there's only thing you only
have at one time from being honest but
I'm having sex with somebody
I don't like and I have no condom mm-hmm
and I come in
oh my god and that and then I wake up
and I couldn't came in real life in the
dream but I'm like [ __ ] man problem this
is now I'm starting this day off god
it's horrible
that's how half of America [ __ ] got
here to have the people that exist since
it became people just say you said
somebody didn't even like somebody
didn't really really really like them at
their core probably do people have a
jacket I didn't know a lot of people
that didn't really enjoy a bit yeah
that's unbelievable enable horrible yeah
that's a terrible note to end on
yeah it is man but that's life huh yeah
[Laughter]
man you have a new album that tattoo if
people want to hear uh songs from across
your journey yeah I know I actually made
that made this thing before I left okay
I made an album basically for myself to
listen to when it got hard and so I made
these songs and I got little messages
from people I respect like Steven Tyler
from Aerosmith yeah he's Diddy and my
mom and bun be 40 and so there's the
songs and there's little messages from
them basically saying what they wanted
me to remember when it got hard and I
made this this whole project for myself
remind myself who I am and then you know
after I walked with the walk started to
put it put songs out and then put the
whole mixtape out I call mixtape puss
out it's called keep going keep going
yeah I'm gonna keep going man that's
right boy amen
I appreciate you all that all the all
the happiness you felt and the world
happiness you gave me you I can't tell
you how much we laugh well thank you in
the car on the way over just laughs I'm
glad to I'm glad to be reminded that
that's what I'm doing cuz sometimes yeah
you get it a little bit confused you
know it's because the point right I was
I'm making music I'm walking across
America right it's supposed to you know
nourish me make me
a better person at the same time
hopefully help others along the way make
their journey a little easier and what
you're doing here well I think a lot of
it you know a lot of our listeners I
think are you know I mean it's what L
it's what it's it's outside of the walk
you know it's the it's the walk that's
going on inside of all of us you know I
think a lot of young men and women and
even strong lesbians are feeling that
[ __ ] right now for everybody they know
so we're out there man but uh thank you
for being here Michael you gotta
appreciate it man
[Music]
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]